s'il vous plaît bonjour on cherche
Laurent Baffie merci
[Musique]
vous battez pas Martine Nicolas
[Applaudissements]
depuis des années en plus des caméras
cachées
papa revient je reviens
allez
waouh c'est beau et c'est toi qui a fait
ça tout seul
et ça c'est quoi ça c'est un gant
virtuel qui matérialise toutes tes
pensées je peux le mettre bien sûr et tu
peux faire ça
matérialiser ma pensée alors attends
laisse-moi réfléchir à un truc
comme ça
alors moi j'aimerais bien faire un truc
avec des moyens hollywoodiens genre on a
un hélicoptère on va à la campagne et on
atterrit dans une ferme on la fait
croire qu'il y a une chasse au trésor et
le bouton vert le bouton vert
[Musique]
en tout cas ton gant il est génial
c'est la chasse au trésor bonjour vous
êtes madame courtier
Paris où est le poulailler 12 minutes 12
minutes madame venez avec nous
10 minutes 10 minutes
ça y est nous venons de trouver le
premier à 10
dans le salon tu auras la moins qu'on le
[__] le salon le salon vite le salon
Sylvie
vous rentrez pas tous dans la maison
c'est la chanson trésor monsieur
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire où se
trouve
le trésor
l'indice on a 8 minutes Paris 7 minutes
indice je peux pas vous dire je suis
bonne continuation
vous êtes trompé
bonjour monsieur le
foot le poulailler s'il vous plaît
vite
il reste 8 minutes
comment sont les œufs paris les œufs
sont jaunes non c'est pas celui-là je la
tape top Paris
oh non c'est pas le bon
homme
Paris voilà nous avons la viande dans le
salon tu suivras mes instructions
le salon le salon venez suivez-moi
le troisième indice dans la cuisine va
fouiller dans la farine la cuisine
c'est ça que tu cherches quoi oui oui
c'est ça Paris top Paris top Paris nous
avons le l'autre indice alors dans le
jardin cherche le parchemin
il nous reste plus que 2 minutes
nous avons donc la quatrième et dernière
énigme je suppose
dans la chambre à coucher tu vas pas
trouver
doucement oh là là
c'est la carte top c'est la carte c'est
la carte du Trésor Paris
[Musique]